bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette édition
du lundi 23 mars voici tout d'abord ce
qu'on peut retenir cette nouvelle
session d'information pourrait
sélections départementales les yvelinois
se sont moins mobilisés que dans le
reste de la france 45 % c'est le taux de
participation
les partis de droite arrive en tête
devant le front national et le parti
socialiste
réactions et résultats la semaine de la
santé mentale j'ai jusqu'à vendredi ce
soir l'institut marcel rivière de la
verrière une pièce de théâtre et jouer
autour du thème de l'école ou comme
montre libérer la parole et puis pierre
gattaz le président du medef invitée de
la fédération yvelinoise pour donner son
sentiment sur la santé les entreprises
s'y livrant groupe s'en sortent il reste
encore beaucoup à faire pour les tpe et
les pme
un peu moins de 45% des électeurs
héninois se sont déplacés aux urnes ce
dimanche ses cinq points de moins que la
moyenne nationale
aucun conseiller départemental et lui
faire dès ce premier tour les parties et
de la droite ump udf modem arrive en
tête dans ce scrutin suivi par le front
national et le parti socialiste dans les
yvelines
aucun élu dès le premier tour les
électeurs héninois son don tous appelés
aux urnes dimanche prochain
selon les chiffres fournis par la
préfecture l'union de la droite qui
avait présenté des binômes ump udi et
modem recueille 21,17 % des suffrages
la droite qui dans sa globalité arrive
en tête dans les 21 cantons
les électeurs sont assez lucide en
réalité ils ont su discerner que l'union
de du centre de la droite est une union
qui va vers l'intérêt général le front
national arrive en seconde position dans
le département avec 23% des suffrages le
parti de marine le pen qui arrive à
qualifier pour le second tour huit
binômes sur les 21 présenter contrat
rempli
c'est une super soirée parce qu on a
augmenté par rapport à l'élection
précédente avec encore plus de
participation donc encore beaucoup plus
de voix donc on est très content quand
on a progressé dans tous les cantons
dans le département le parti socialiste
totalise 16 89% des voix c'est loin
derrière la droite et le front national
les yvelines avait quand même très mal
voter ça aussi il faudra s'interroger
sur ce baisse de civisme dans notre
département
deuxième élément c'est la division à
gauche qui nous nous oblige aujourd'hui
à nous reposer la question de comment on
fait travailler l'ensemble des forces de
gauche ensemble et puis la troisième
chose c'est effectivement la percée de
dans l'électorat populaire du vote fn
il ya des messages qui font entendre et
que on peut pas balayer ça d'un revers
de main sur notre secteur plus
précisément sur les cantons de trappes
montigny le bretonneux bon repas saint
cyr l'école ou encore plaisir
ce sont des duels classiques union de la
droite ps que les électeurs vont devoir
arbitrer
à noter que des duels union de la droite
fn seront arbitrés aussi pour les
électeurs c'est le cas à mantes la jolie
où le binôme de pierre bédier sera
opposé au binôme porté par cyril note le
maire fn de mantes-la-ville à
rambouillet christine boutin conseillère
générale sortante devra batailler aussi
contre un binôme emmené par le front
national ce qui peut faire la différence
pour ce second tour c'est la
mobilisation des électeurs dans les
yvelines ce dimanche 45 34 % des
électeurs se sont déplacés aux urnes ces
cinq points de moins qu'au niveau
national
justement maintenant je vous propose de
jeter un coup d'oeil sur les cantons de
notre secteur des doigts elles attendent
les électeurs dimanche prochain tout
d'abord à montigny le bretonneux le
binôme du maire de montigny et présente
la casse qui michel logis et laurence
rochus sera opposé au binôme du
conseiller général sortant maire de
guyancourt le socialiste françois denis
et sandrine bombe sur le canton de
trappes maintenant jeanine marie
conseillère générale sortante allié à
allinges âge maire de la verrière
tentera de conserver son fauteuil face
au binôme de l'ump menée par le maire
d'elancourt premier vice-président de la
casse qui jean michel fourgous et anne
capio sur le canton de maurepas c'est un
duel qui oppose deux conseillers
généraux sortants d'un côté arrivées en
tête
le binôme union de la droite yves
orgeval alexandra rosetti et de l'autre
le binôme socialiste ismaila vannes et
christine mercier sur le canton de saint
cyr l'école le conseiller général
sortant socialiste jean philippe mallet
associé à fabienne gelgon bilbo tentera
de conserver son fauteuil face au binôme
arrivé en tête à l'issue de ce premier
tour philippe benassaya maire ump de
bois d'arcy et sonia breux
et puis enfin sur le canton de plaisir
le conseiller général sortant socialiste
jean michel jean michel gourdon ne se
représentait pas le binôme socialiste
nicolas et frédéric evrard compte 16
points de retard avec le binôme de
l'union de la droite représentée par la
mère de plaisir joséphine cole john
berger et bertrand coquard de lui dit
que pensez vous justement des résultats
de ces élections départementales c'est
la question que nous sommes à aller vous
poser dans les rues de saint quentin en
yvelines voici vos réponses
bon j'étais prévu le parti socialiste a
pris une déculottée quoi enfin bon c'est
est prévu un peu pense pas que ça va
changer grand chose mais en amour je
m'aperçois que personne n'est content
c'est un petit peu nationale bon c'était
prévisible
ça montre un peu une efficacité du
gouvernement mais de toute façon on a
toujours eu un pays divisé entre deux
parties il à droite et la gauche
alors il est normal que la plupart des
gens mécontents et aillent voter
ailleurs personnellement mais je suis
assez contente de la bonne position de
la de l'ump udi moins pire que ça ce que
ça aurait pu être pour le gouvernement
actuel
moi personnellement ça m'intéresse pas
vraiment j'ai jamais voté de ma vie
comme disait coluche
si les élections servent à quelque chose
depuis longtemps ça serait interdite
même aller voter c'est un droit civique
et si vous voulez tout connaître de
l'ensemble des résultats de votre canton
de votre commune et les réactions vous
avez rendez vous dans quelques instants
avec le 7-8 politique présentée par
wilfrid richy dans le reste de
l'actualité le mouvement de grève est
toujours maintenue europcar à fouassin
le bretonneux selon les syndicalistes
une grande partie de l'équipe en place
soit une trentaine de personnes a cessé
le travail depuis mercredi dernier
en cause toujours selon le personnel le
choix de la société d'externaliser ses
des services informatiques
cette externalisation pourrait se faire
début avril
et pour cela les salariés demandent des
compensations financières à hauteur de
50 mille euros pour l'heure la direction
n'a pas donné suite à leur demande
chaque jour les salariés se réunissent
pour savoir s'ils poursuivent nous
mouvement économie toujours à la
celle-saint-cloud les chefs d'entreprise
avaient rendez vous avec pierre gattaz
le président du medef il a répondu à
l'invitation de la fédération yvelinoise
une rencontre pour parler
petit tivité et confiance et nous lui
avons justement demandé quels étaient
selon lui l'état d'esprit des chefs
d'entreprise s'il y a du mieux pour les
grands groupes
pierre gattaz reconnaît que beaucoup de
choses restent à faire pour les tpe et
pme
on l'écouté au micro de michael mais
theuriau nous sentons des tout petits
frémissements liées au dollar qui est
levée qui a remonté et moi l'euro kbc
par trop dollar par rapport aux taux
d'intérêt qui sont faibles le pétrole
qui est faible tout ça sont des bons
signaux extérieurs
je pense qu'il ya un peu le pacte de
responsabilité qui commence à donner des
du coût du travail qui s'allège un tout
petit peu donc ce sont des bourses des
bons signaux principal en extérieur qui
va nous permettre sans doute de recréer
un peu de croissance en france ce dont
je doute c'est que ça suffira pour
vraiment recréer de l'emploi massivement
les perspectives c'est autour de 1% de
croissance cette année pour créer de
l'emploi il faut 1,5 au minimum travail
en profondeur sur la législation du
travail j'insiste beaucoup
il faut donner de la flexibilité de la
flexisécurité au marché du travail
il faut continuer de réduire avec
courage les taxes les charges des impôts
nous avons encore un niveau de taxes et
de charges très élevé faisons tout pour
qu'ils aient plus entrepreneurs qu'ils
soient mieux qu'ils vivent mieux qui se
développe plus facilement en france et
vous verrez que la machine à croissance
repartira avec earl chinna qu a créé
l'emploi repartira mais aujourd'hui
c'est encore on hésite voit la société
maintenant dans le cadre de la 26e
semaine d'information sur la santé
mentale les faits théâtre à la maison
des adolescents des yvelines et le lieu
écoute jeunes propose je ne veux pas y
aller
une pièce pour libérer la parole en
milieu scolaire cette pièce est
justement jouer ce lundi soir l'institut
marcel rivière de la verrière et yolaine
thorez et william elles ont assisté aux
dernières répétitions pas toujours
facile
mais non c'est pas vrai c'est déjà pas
forcément besoin
c'est un programme qui est très
intéressant ces terres qu'on s'amuse on
passe un bon moment à la fois une partie
d'une pièce de théâtre qui dure une
demi-heure s'est vite mais on n'a pas le
temps de s'ennuyer
on voit un panel de plein de personnages
et puis la formule fait qu'après il ya
une partie de débat une partie
interactive une partie où ils ont droit
de proposer des solutions
la thématique en elle même c'est une
thématique hyper actuelle question de la
peur à l'école à la fois vis-à-vis d'un
professeur et la fois vis-à-vis d'un
collégien voilà cette notion de j'ai pas
envie d'aller à l'école je me sens pas
bien dans cet environnement et c'est une
thématique pas qui était une commande au
départ ou qui est qui est très actuel il
s'attend sur saisissante réussi dans le
futur
corinne c'est c'est la professeure de
français d'arthur elle est dans un
moment de stress assez intense où elle a
l'impression que les gens se liguent
contre elle que la moindre chose est une
montagne a du mal à mon à prendre un peu
de distance à respirer et puis un
premier poste où le seul objectif c'est
d'éviter les coups profit des élèves qui
comprennent pas ce qu'ils ont à nous
prendre joue arthur qui est un jeune
collégien en 4e et en 3e jouant un jeune
et un élève perturbateur de zep un cpe
rapidement et le perd un parent d'élève
je crois que ça fait 4 qui se baladent
sur une pièce de 35 heures on est
comédien
donc le but de la pièce c2c de pouvoir
parler plus facilement des personnages
de leur problématique parce que ils
viennent de le voir que c'est encore
frais qu'eux on essaye dans l'écriture
de coller au maximum à la réalité dans
le cd de cash en disant on n'est pas en
fait pas d'eux
on évite la mièvrerie et mine de rien on
évite aussi la caricature c'est qu'il ne
s'agit pas de montrer quelque chose de
trop exagéré il faut que les gens
s'identifient il faut qu'ils puissent se
dire ouais j'ai quand même dit on à
devoir aller santé toujours comme chaque
année des étudiants de médecine de
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
installe quelques heures un hôpital des
nounours l'occasion pour des enfants de
maternelle de découvrir de manière
ludique comment fonctionne un hôpital et
surtout de ne pas avoir peur si un jour
il se retrouve confronté à une
hospitalisation
mélanie poker raphaël cinq ans et
quelque peu impressionnés difficile pour
lui expliquer ce cas nounours son panda
alors blandine de nour ce lock propose
un contrôle de routine nounours à une
otite
cette étudiante en médecine fait partie
des bénévoles de l'association poèmes
qui chaque année organise l'hôpital des
nombreuses les enfants sont pas malades
donc on peut pas vraiment les soigner on
peut pas leur faire un faux hôpital ont
fait semblant de les opérer
donc le nounours était une bonne
alternative voilà c'est sympa pour eux
c'est leur doudou c'est pas l'heure du
personnel par contre s'est passé avec
lequel ils demandent c'est une peluche
qui avait chez eux l'hôpital des
nounours est un moyen de réduire
l'angoissé l'appréhension de tout petits
au palmarès de ces consultations gastro
entérite varicelle est fracturé pour
soigner tous ces bobos dentiste radionov
le coopérateur et salles de soins
alexane elle a fait soigner cloud et
s'appelle une allergie au lait on a
décidé de shy'm piqûre on a tapoté
partout où elle avait mal on les a donné
plusieurs médicaments
cette année l'hôpital des nounours a
reçu 450 deux enfants est mobilisé près
de 150 étudiants de 2e année de
l'université de médecine de 50 en mai
ce journal est maintenant terminé merci
de votre attention rendez vous demain à
18 heures pour une nouvelle session
d'information d'ici là bonne soirée
il